[Music]
welcome one and all to the h3 experience
extravagance also known as the podcast
you got to hype it up we are back with
the greatest episode we have ever
produced here of all time um you can't
say that I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding
this we're actually not doing much worth
goofin we're chilling we're chatting
when this is a very mediocre episode
we're just sitting here you know every
time it's like this is the best episode
of no this is a very mediocre up so let
me be upfront with you but sometimes the
mediocre ones are the best
maybe you you'll never know so you
unless you watch yeah well I'm just
trying to keep them interested cuz you
don't wanna be like hey it's mediocre
and I'm like well alright please turn it
off
um the media under ones are sometimes
the best and you guys all watching know
exactly what I'm talking about we got
some great stories let me just say that
today's episode is sponsored by an VMT
movement Squarespace in hims great let
me also say that we've got a wonderful
guest who's coming up after the break
William Osmond he's this incredible
engineer that makes basically products
that shouldn't exist
he's got the series he calls they didn't
ask for it but we made it anyways and he
made for me a coughing beanie which we
didn't ask for everybody might even ask
for it but he sure made it but it's
really cool and more interestingly he
was his house interestingly but
tragically let's say his house burned
down during the crazy Ventura fires I'm
sure you guys all remember yeah during
the construction of the beanie itself so
I am looking forward to chatting with
him about all of that I'm also excited
to tell you guys that the next four
weeks are insane our schedule Tom Segura
next week on June 15th buggie yeah boi
boogie2988 back on June 19th the next
week Chris D'Elia
June 29th and in July 6 we got Bo
Burnham Wow
a freaking house Wow thank you
Wow well I was right Wow thank you thank
you
and Dean can we get the Owen Wilson well
he already did your snoozing on the Wow
now get either going Wow Wow thank you
yeah I'm actually I'm so excited for all
these guys coming up I'm excited to be
here today with you because well let me
just say this that after today I'm sad
to say they were giving shredder to my
parents tonight which is so tragic it
seems so wrong to just sleep in our home
but they'll shred you but the reason
being is that tomorrow morning we are
going on vacation for my birthday it's
like make sure I mention you're going on
vacation and now shrivel is mine
shredder it's okay maybe that amount
what'd I tell you guys this one mediocre
or what all right sometimes they're the
best though close the door sometimes the
mediocre ones are the best we are live
villa for christ sake we're live have a
seat let's move on what'd I tell you did
we put on a good show uh but let's see
here I there there's a lot I want to get
to but let's cut to the chase cuz there
came up a clip of a news broadcast and I
love like [ __ ] Eve news broadcast
they're just always good but this is
like pure distilled cringe and the heart
of a star under gravity of gravitational
forces basically a black hole of cringe
it's so powerful and so great Dan go
ahead and roll it you know usually the
world of inflation
you guys drink it we notice is that a
good thing we got inflation
all right started over on you know
usually when you're talking about the
world of inflation you guys you probably
notice is that a good thing or or not a
good thing
inflation
I'm sorry the question again Dave is the
inflation in our world a good thing or
not a good thing it depends upon what
the title is what are we talking about
so he's an ad like this inflation con
like yeah inflate a balloon and so he's
trying so hard for this bun and I love
how he like Mouse his head like he's
waiting he's like he needs the answer
from back home in the studio is it a
good thing or a bad thing
and and I don't think that the guy in
the studio can hear or he can't see so
he's actually nobody's talking about was
it trying to make it Joe
yes is inflation a good thing or a bad
thing he's just like what are you
talking about Bob guys roll it in a
solution if you have an inflatable boat
you see if you heard the wind you right
but generally when you hear the word
inflation not economical good come to
mind yeah for me yeah yeah
well let me tell you that you're right
about if you say good you're right
because this is the world of inflatables
give yourselves a nice round of applause
everybody these are just a volunteers
coming out here today and Abby who
you're gonna have what kind of fun do
you think you're gonna have today what
is that is that the strangest question
you could ask someone what kind of fun
what kind of how many options are there
regular
bounce it regular fun what kind of fun
do you expect to have today here let's
see how she has lots of fun that's it
that's a good kind hoping just helping
everybody do you think you can find here
today what does that mean yeah I think
so because looking for someone say
bouncy Ollie's can come and kind of
bounce around but you need something and
I'm gonna have everyone do it like a
magic chant all right you guys ready
because when we're talking inflatables
can you buy some all these poor sons of
[ __ ] it looks like it's 8 a.m.
these guys are all working you know they
started at the beginning of a really
long day and they did not sign up for
this [ __ ] man he's about that he's about
to have him all start chanting and
clapping and [ __ ] so he's just a TV
reporter yeah what kind of fun do you
expect to have on our vacation you know
bouncy fun bouncy why would you have
bouncy fun that's been inflated are you
guys ready repeat after me
abracadabra 1 2 3
so much Tara like just you know I'm not
saying that my goodness they said it
this is an honor first of all well thank
you i we are local san diegoans so we're
proud to be here everybody on this
wonderful beautiful Saturday morning
welcome San Diego I just think you know
this is so much fun here first I posit
mister wacky's really got it together
man anyone there
he's like the most coherent person there
I wonder what kind of fun he's expecting
to have today wacky fun maybe black yeah
that's a great is there more does this
finish off with the strong little bang
there yeah yeah I had the crims
continues it's longer than a 5k right
well yes each participant has the option
a lap as many times as they want we're
out here trying to get really Alan mr.
William business families in San Diego
so we're really excited to be here we
have all kinds of attractions behind us
and of course that family they want with
inflatables on them labels on us I mean
everybody here becomes an inflatable
today do they want to be inflatables
today you guys want to be inflatable
yeah absolutely
people are adult well that's why they're
all like good I inside the big Becky is
doing the mr. wacky right now yeah you
got his head down mr. Fleming is not
there oh no I think he's texting he
should that guy was text out he was not
having any of this [ __ ] let me see yeah
this guy's a hero that's the guy that
also didn't repeat what yes tours like I
don't get paid enough for this mr. wacky
bull attendees can enjoy bounce houses
live music food and dancing I love this
guy
you know can you go back to the
beginning Dan cuz that definitely still
is my favorite part when the with that
joke which is crush go ahead let me see
this the world of inflation you guys you
probably noticed is that a good thing or
or not a good thing inflation such a
good setup you know and you had the
thing about it that's such a good stuff
is I don't know how to answer that
like he's expecting an answer I guess he
was expecting him say it's bad inflation
is bad but maybe it's good I don't know
price that's a bad moment you see this
guy this was on dad morning at yeah dad
morning a San Diego dad morning to you
shout out to all the dads it's 58
degrees out here in dad morning San
Diego dad of the morning to you go ahead
play I just wanna I want to see this I'm
sorry the question again Dave is
inflation in your lie I love it though
dad in the morning Tia as inflation
generally more of a dad thing or uh I'm
waiting for you to answer all right that
was it that was a special thing know
what that was
you know it's rare to come across a true
beautiful gem like that and I said hey
let's start this episode off right
because frankly we've got
thing else going from episode we've got
actually the show we're ready to wrap it
up I'm kidding I want first of all I'm
that's not a true we've got William
Osmond and I don't mean to uh you know
make it sound like he's not amazing who
did air alright today FBI
off-duty agent drops gun this I love so
effing good you know it's funny I saw
that video and I didn't know that was an
FBI guy well he's not in uh he's an
off-duty FBI agent and he's at a dance
off of all places drunk and he's he's
doing some crazy moves you know he's
really getting into it he's losing
himself in the music you know god bless
sometimes it's good to lose yourself in
the music like Ian last night Kanye Dan
got in into the Kanye preesh live what
do you call that [ __ ] how do you call it
a listening party listening party and I
got a clip of of Ian by the bonfire look
at he's in the tribal trance sometimes
you got to be in that travel yeah but
when those times happen don't have a
loaded gun on you know so this FBI guy
well let's just go ahead and watch look
at those moves
[Music]
[Applause]
got him see what here's my favorite part
why she's like my bad my bad y'all so he
actually shot somebody
yeah poor son of a [ __ ] in the foot my
bad how was it more but my bad orzo
wasn't me
no it was my bad my bad y'all FBI I
think it's under control and like took
it must have happened that he went and
grabbed the gun and pulled the trigger
on accident right which apply no why the
guns don't just go off when you drop it
not look that's a movie thing can we
play
yeah let's replay it because well it
also implies that the safety wasn't even
on I mean what though yeah freak happen
here now yeah you're loaded take it easy
I mean it he grabbed it yeah but he
barely touches it I know but like it was
already settled on the floor yeah I
think he must have pulled the trigger
he's clearly very drunk so the safety
wasn't on damn dog you're packing heat
so this this legend shots him on the
foot but was actually even better was
the guy who got shots reaction to being
shot you have that Dan
this guy's a [ __ ] ledge chorizo I had
to a screencap it all right from CNN or
whatever the [ __ ] so here we go now I
want charissa do you want this news
anchors intro I want jack-in-the-box a
dance no good just go to his viral video
we showed you earlier this week I wrote
it yeah this viral video
inflatable wacky man day this video got
a million hate I know what everyone
calls it a No
to skip to the they go to the leg with
friends at this Denver bar over the
weekend when 29 year-old rehabbed what
happened they're gonna circle it watch
his leg covered in blood
somebody called 911 and I blacked out
and I woke up to such a regular guy
finding tourniquets Reddington says his
injury is putting his physically
demanding job at risk walking is next to
impossible but he says after watching
this video dozen times but when I saw
him do a backflip I couldn't help but
laugh I don't blame the guy I don't want
to ruin his life the FBI tells ABC that
agent Bishop will be held accountable
and could also face criminal charges
Denver police say they're still waiting
I just love that guy I just couldn't
help but and he even goes as far to say
I don't want him to lose his job frankly
I do
that's FBI man grace it also I love that
screen cap of the FBI agent just smiling
at the camera with the shitty and grin
like you up there that was it like yup I
did yep my bad
damn he seems like he's you know just
enjoying life he's happy-go-lucky but
enjoying a little too much exactly FBI
supposed to have the collar on tight no
enjoyment I prefer my FBI agents with no
enjoyment see what happens when they
have fun no he needs to go down in a
statement from the bar they said they
hope the man will quit quickly return to
good condition and added that he will
receive complimentary free drinks
forever if he ever comes back that's
[ __ ] by the way if you're trying to
date that's sick you bring them to that
bar
not only to get free drinks all night
like I was shot in the leg here yeah
every drinks for life
that's pretty legit no that's the only
bar is gonna go to that's all I would go
to also not even for the free drinks
just for the street cred like this guy
was shot here they're gonna play like a
statue of him they should why did his
foot have two bullet holes and is anyone
questioning the what's going on
yeah it's that was that was a head
scratcher maybe that's like just uh
maybe that wasn't the bullet wound maybe
that was from the tourniquet they put on
or something I don't know I may be
related to an explanation of what I
think happened is he shot himself twice
said it was him that got shot so he can
get free drinks for life what I think
happened is that nobody got shot at all
never me I'm conspiracy FBI conspiracy
for lifetime free drinks yeah dude we
have the wackiest frickin stories today
dr. booty man hmm dr. booty I said boot
ate you right so this this is probably
it's funny we weren't gonna talk about
it I heard this on the radio as we were
parking in the office I know and I was
like oh my god this is incredible so
this woman her first of all I'm calling
her dr. booty but her actual last name
is bootay yeah how's that spelled damn
do you have it back there just like
booty butt with it oh here it was the
own Bo you tte okay dr. booty she's a
dermatologist that when patients were
under and without their consent she
would start dancing and recording it
like doing little bits and putting it on
YouTube she's doing [ __ ] well she's got
a scalpel doing a surgery and she's like
doing it on the beat like oh it's the
craziest [ __ ] ever car and not only that
I mean we've got footage here but like
um a hundred people apparently are suing
her for having botched surgeries Wow one
lawsuit claims that after eight hours of
surgery
someone sustained permanent brain damage
from a dermatologist dancing how the
[ __ ] does it dermatologists give someone
brain damage oh my god
and another she's leaning over the top
of patients bare buttocks without
surgical masks or gloves
she holds surgical instruments and
dances while wrapping her own lyrics to
me goes bad and Yuji my painter my
patients are bad and bougie building up
fat and the booty that's what she said
take it away you know what open right
there's a beyblade cadaver but like to
think like hey what the Sun you should
Jimmy Lee and suck up with her the
dentist has a dermatologist anybody like
she's a serial offender you know what I
mean - yeah
Oh horrible so she's done this hundreds
of times and she had the all these
videos on our YouTube channel and I
guess somebody made a complaint some
regulatory board like hey you know maybe
you shouldn't be doing surgery while
dancing and recording without permission
without using surgical gloves or being
sanitary or paying attention to your
open patient with the scalpel a crazy
man that's so scary it makes me think
like whenever you go to weird doctor and
you have all this like scary thoughts in
your head like real man they're all real
what do you think Jimmy Lee does too
when your honor and she put it on
YouTube yeah did she have subscribers
like what I don't know that it's the
channels gone now I wonder how many subs
she had yeah it's interesting its unique
content was he titled them this morning
when we heard this story they put played
a sound bite of her saying I did my
soul-searching and I have done nothing
wrong they're like do you think that um
now that you have had time to reflect do
you think you've done anything wrong I
love that line I've done soul-searching
I've searched my soul I've meditated
deep and long about this and I've
concluded I've done nothing wrong
ever in my life how what kind of sauce
you didn't you didn't search deep enough
keep searching
your soul has many crevices left still
to search but I wonder what she titled
her videos opera Nicki Minaj Wow hasn't
gone wrong right live operation Nicki
Minaj Beauty what's the name of that uh
uh bad and bougie bad and bougie live
while operating on a patient and the
thing is they blurring them in this
video but I think you could see some
bare asses and like naked cadavers what
they didn't know there be filmed a prop
the story is unbelievable lover dr.
booty and Jimmy Lee we need a crossover
of a lie
those new together yeah I'm just I'm
salivating so um let's take a quick
break when we come back we will be here
with your boy William Osmond with the
coughing beam Ian it's a really cool
invention a great story I think you guys
gonna love this guy after that we've got
some great gaffes to get to I've got
this segment about reporters destroying
[ __ ] like while they interview people
like you know school record [ __ ] they're
like hey how's it going then they topple
the whole thing I love no but I've got a
conspiracy about it till we've been we
we we noticed a trend
and we're suspicious and we have
thoughts that we'd like to share in fact
we should have people call in dan only
get some thoughts on that okay so don't
go away
we will be right back after this
commercial break
see you soon thank you to movement and
VMT for sponsoring this episode
listen do you understand what a nice
watch can do to your look that extra
little touch of class that makes your
dick extra touchable and my dick ela if
you saw a guy with a watch like this
what are the chances that you would
touch his dick as opposed to not 100%
whoa you heard it here I don't want you
hanging around any other guys with
movement watches [ __ ] I'm the only one
you guys know about movement these two
close dropouts have started their own
wash company this company's growing like
crazy and now with almost 2 million
watches sold in 160 countries they
continue to revolutionize fashion the
belief that on the belief that style
should not break the bank I don't know
if you've checked out the site lately
but they've doubled the number of watch
styles and are still expanding ok if you
go to the store you're looking at maybe
four to five hundred dollars for a watch
of this quality but at MVM t know
starting at $95 this think you could
take a bullet like Wonder Woman don't
try it
I am also wearing their bracelet yeah
that bracelet honestly it looks insane
now here's what I'm pitching to you guys
they've got sunglasses too
Father's Day is coming up
and you know dads love their washes okay
and if you go to nvm t.com /hd you will
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns that's MVM t.com slash h3
see why they keep growing and expanding
like crazy it's not for no reason
let me give you a hint the products
amazing and you're gonna love it and the
price is mind-blowing okay so head on
back over to MB mc.com slash h3 it makes
a perfect gift and let me tell you get
this for your dad and I I think if you
buy your dad a nice watch for Father's
Day
that's pretty killer I might actually
take they're making their own it's funny
my dad's watching this and he's like all
right I know if I don't end up buying
this watch for my dad now I'm screwed
I'm going to it's a perfect place to
shop for an affordable timeless gift go
to nvm t.com slash h3 and join the
flippin movement this episode is
sponsored by Squarespace whether you
need a domain website or online store
make it with Squarespace here's the deal
they've got beautiful designer templates
that make creating a powerful online
identity easy even easier each template
is a starting point for a wide range of
project whether you're pursuing your
side hustle or promoting your main gig
Squarespace has got that one-stop shop
this is gonna make it all come together
and make your dreams reality one of
those exactly you look it's an
all-in-one platform
they've got create a beautiful website
it's just there's nothing to install
patch or upgrade ever it's just so easy
award-winning 24/7 customer service they
provide
who does that these days if you're
having a problem you get a couple they
they're winning award so let me just put
it that way if you don't believe me it's
simple to set up or transfer your
domains on Squarespace domain transfer
you can now transfer your third-party
domains to Squarespace instead of
working with multiple vendors to
maintain your online presence you're
able to manage all your domains of
billing setup with Squarespace and take
advantage of our easy to use DNS
interface enough that BS with any other
crap
you can switch it over and it's all in
one that's the beauty of it it's never
been easier to sell products or services
online
Squarespace allows you to manage your
products orders and inventory easily so
guys listen making a website seems like
a big deal it's daunting it's awful it
seems like better but here's what
Squarespace does they make it fun they
make it exciting they make it easy and
when you're done you're gonna think wow
how did I create such a beautiful
website when I'm just some incompetent
idiot that can barely even type that's
the power of Squarespace so head on over
to squarespace.com slash h3 to try it
free for 14 days and to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain again that's squarespace.com
slash h3 let me ask you does your dick
need a flick is it a little soft and it
should be a little try to think of right
soft eft well sexual performance issues
are way more in common than you think
over 25% of new IDI cases are guys under
the age of 40 fatty coding or my case
guys under the age of 33 for hims come a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men thanks to
science edy can now be optional hims
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
limp [ __ ]
they say edy but let's be frank well no
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you combat edy
that stands for erectile dysfunction aka
limp [ __ ] LD LD Larry David L diva then
LD o see in this game well let's let's
let's focus
all right prescription solutions are
backed by science so this is the real
deal folks answer a few quick questions
and chat with a doctor for a
confidential review products are shipped
directly to your door severe Edie isn't
just an issue for rich old guys well
clearly it's not just for rich people
they're like oh not only do not only do
rich old guys dicks not worth
that's stigma now yeah like the the
commercials are always like rich old
guys barbecuing and smiling and stuff
and all their problems over know that
they can get a hard-on again it affects
men in the 30s and 40s as well being
your best means performing your best
it's a reptile without the dysfunction
hard made easy say hello to your little
friend or in my case to your microscopic
friend
say hello to my mini friend try him for
a month today for just five bucks we'll
get you started for just five bucks
while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds of bucks if you went to
the doctor or the pharmacy so go to four
hams calm / h3e D that's fo r hims calm
/ h 3e d 4 hams calm / 83 EDD thank you
all so much
let's get right back into it
we're back hey guys thanks for sticking
around so as promised we've got here the
inventor of the coughing beanie himself
William husband the owner of the
incredible YouTube channel named after
himself
William Osmond owner owner creator
Trailblazer kind of weird I don't like
you can get a little close to the mic on
that prepositions are sensitive yeah how
do you feel about the word youtuber it's
fine you know wrong with it I don't mind
it as much as I should
I feel like how long have you been doing
YouTube professionally like making money
yeah I live in your old half nice that's
good not making money like 10 years 10
years really I guess we had like two
years of of not making money but we
started like pretty late you know did
you go in with the intention of making
money no no no we didn't even know it
was an option but I'm not listen Oh a
small chapel what's [ __ ] on your head
yeah oh you know just what's on your
head
right what is only $19 your beanie is
making me very insecure things bigger it
is much bigger I can turn it on so you
have a series called they didn't ask for
it but I made it anyways right I didn't
ask for it but we made it and sent it to
the manual right so you finally
fulfilling a promise of sending it can
you see that Dan oh yeah we we're seeing
it alright
you getting the sound that looks so good
you know what you know what it is it's
like the Harry Potter hat yeah the
sorting hats trashy yeah exactly and we
can we can rig it up to blast smoke out
to and so you can control it with some
smoky do you have to like take it apart
and like I can do it yeah no don't worry
about it don't worry about no it's okay
let's see the smoke I'll use Maria as my
kind of falls off the head though so oh
my god I can't I'm hearing myself dying
over there
come on the animations are all done by
shut up Jeremy and John didn't wanna
take so much of myself there's a switch
in here somewhere I can't find it help
we can't turn it off okay so the story
of this beanie
creation is also an interesting one
interesting a nice word for tragic one I
would say interesting I mean like
hindsight it was a fantastic experience
really well what happened let's start
there people know look basically my
house burned down yeah from the
wildfires and and you grew up there so
you probably know a lot of the areas
that were affected yeah and we were in
the middle of working on this project
like that night of and of all the stuff
I grabbed all the pieces we had cut on
the laser cutter came with us like I
mean we left we left all sorts of stuff
but mostly the beanie most of the beanie
I wanted to acknowledge thank you saved
you save my baby
your meaning and I always wonder like
how many things did you get to save the
I knew it was coming
yeah but the problem is nobody thinks
their house is gonna yeah yeah so you
kind of assume like what do I really
need if I I'm gonna lose all my stuff
what do I really care about but what
what you realize in the end is I should
just spent an extra 20 minutes filling
the car up i was i brought my computer
and like my tower I even felt kind of
stupid for dragging out of it because
you don't expect yeah you're like yeah
I'm overreacting my house isn't gonna
burn down I'm overreacting right and you
know I'm sort of in my head like some of
the stuff we do I don't know how much of
our videos you guys ever watch but like
if anyone's gonna burn my house down
it's gonna be me yeah nature and so
we're your neighbors spared or was a
like a God was like [ __ ] you
specifically yeah we got we got smited
but it's not I don't think it's I don't
know if it's entirely nature but what
happened was there was no water so power
went out
the pumps weren't replenishing the water
tanks up on the hills and so they were
conserving water like fire trucks could
not get water serving they like so like
well it's it's I mean it kind of makes
sense so they go to a house they see the
garage is already on
fire because we lived in a studio
attached to the house that was a
converted garage and so they're like
let's conserve our water save the house
and put out like minimally in between
the house in the garage but the garage
burned what they didn't realize when we
walked up and they're like we saved the
house is that was our house though the
main house the neighbors that lived in
there were pretty much spared - their
stuff that was actually in the it's you
know they still lost but it looked like
well we have a clip Dan can you roll it
of the because what I saw was just ruins
it was apocalyptic straight-up
apocalyptic do you have the clip down yo
it's your boy here William Osmond here
this is a country house tour yeah things
have changed we moved some furnace ones
or just we got the idea at the beginning
that yeah to see how was there anything
spared cuz it looks like a total
apocalypse there
well the neighbor's house was totally
fine a separate separate it's a detached
unit or mostly detectives like an awning
between the two so the firefighters were
basically trying to prevent it from
spreading to the house instead of
putting it because they like they were
literally running on no water like I
think someone had like a quarter tank
and they're they're just saying I'm not
fair like come back up here like we need
you know on all my time in Ventura I
mean we both grew up there around the
same time nothing like this ever
happened well there's houses that are
like I mean this is not like relatively
old for Ventura but you know people
think of a house 300 years old is old
but houses that had been there for 60 70
years burned down and it's like you know
I mean fires happen but never like right
no it was nothing like that
but although that goes down as the
number one most destructive force fire
in California history right I think I
just saw the sign of Rosa was I think
more houses but I think the Thomas fire
was more acreage I just read like a week
ago that they finally put out the last
flame from this fire oh really yeah
no way yeah that's that's correct the
timeline yeah
it lasted until just a couple weeks ago
but just roll a little more so we can
see though lay the land how long has it
been it's probably been gosh six months
six months Wow like exactly
and this is kind of supposed to be a
joke we got to look at that what kind of
drinks we've got let's show you the
fridge you got that's the strange the
brats
oh they kind of lessen made it I know we
do stuff might make this seem like it
was our fault but he has experienced a
massive wildfire can cause explode I
know you you found one fork that was the
one remaining fork have you cherished
that fork I honestly I honestly don't
know where the four oh no I think we've
got a I don't have any place to keep
stuff can I live in a Motorhome at my
parents house right is that where you
ended up relocating yeah so and and
people support I mean it was I I still
feel like sort of like unworthy of the
support we received but yeah you guys
got like a hundred and seventy thousand
sitting in an account and it's like we
weren't planning on buying a house and I
think a lot of people don't know how
expensive houses are here and they've
never been through the house planning
process it's like you have to prove
income to get a loan you know the
problem is we hadn't made any money that
you're well I hadn't made any money this
is the same exact name right and so you
know now we had to get our taxes done
which was a whole nightmare because of
the fire and you do all the casualty
loss stuff and I just hate doing taxes
too so I do get do get help from the
country for what happened I wonder that
too
so I think we I don't even know what we
lost I mean it's a lot of money worth of
stuff gone like replacement car
not even the mines the time it's the
time you know because you can get
something on Craigslist for GI
collecting a lifetime's worth of yeah
like how the F I think the total like
government compensation was just a five
thousand dollar reduction in your taxes
we have all the stuff we lost that saved
us about five thousand dollars in taxes
which is kind of sad
something yeah it's not yeah I thought
it would be a lot more I did too and and
I did not realize because like [ __ ]
house burned down coupon they were
asking for fair market value like it's
your it's a percentage of fair market
it's fair market value is a deduction so
it's not like replacement cost insurance
this replacement cost depending on your
type of interest so how do you like I'm
cured
always wondered about this your beanies
or should I say my beanie so then you
come my way sit nice that was good
oh no way you can control it so fun just
coming out no I hear burning I think
it's warming up oh I didn't plug the fan
I know the sound of a coil when I hear I
forgot to put that way
it's the beanie even covered up just
look fine yeah it's all of those when we
make things we don't make great things
we make like good enough things you know
it's I'm scriptable skeptical people
that make great things good enough is
all you hear even when they do they lie
about it they'll just show you the final
product and and so you're like wow
they're really good everything starter
yeah and you're like they're not good at
that they struggled a lot to weed you
how to show most of our struggles right
so when you lose every possession you've
ever had like what like that I'm just
curious howdy what's the process like of
like okay you go to the site
everything's gone mm-hmm like what what
do you do um I think you don't know what
to do which is you don't know what to do
you sort of sit there and think about
like what do I do
I mean it's a very lost feeling it's not
a good it's imagine everything stripped
away you don't know what you're doing
the next day you don't know what you're
doing the next week you don't know
anything and like you don't know where
you're gonna live like my parents were
out of the house too we were living my
whole family living in the motor home
because the neighborhood's were locked
out with National Guard and whoa like
armed Humvees and stuff so it's a very
sort of like it's just like lost you
feel very lost and the one thing we had
going was like well we just keep making
YouTube videos and we can do that I use
a camera we have you know we can make
typos and I want a really cool thing you
really don't need anything like people
said take a break we'll understand and
in the end I think making more videos is
kind of what made us feel like more
whole that
had a goal to accomplish and now we had
a you know weird situation that we could
continue doing videos and it was like a
new perspective a new sort of angle I
don't know the weird thing no I know
exactly what you mean the weird thing
for me is like stuff you don't think
about like you losing every article of
clothing yeah
no clothes yeah what about how many
outfits did you have um I think I wore
the same pair of underwear for 48 hours
and at that point I was like we need to
go to the store just buy yeah so crazy
to just be like okay I need underwear
like you don't even realize that you
just sit then you're like it's been two
days and I haven't changed my clothes
yeah what's the like the thing that you
you really were depressed about losing
the maybe you didn't expect but I I
think great question you know I don't
know I would have been really sad if we
had lost hard drives we'd been keeping
everything on an external hard drives
and so we saved all of that which that's
good that would have been devastating
because we had videos filmed and that
was like losing I mean you guys film to
imagine losing a whole video that's it
I'm not forgotten yeah it's a terrifying
experience but you didn't lose we didn't
lose anything just its tools I mean
imagine the the like it wasn't having
lost something it was just not being
able to sort of jump back into
everything as instantaneously as you do
everyday like you wake up in the morning
and I'd make breakfast every day and now
it's like I can't do that it's like
we're going to jack-in-the-box we're
going to like fast food places that are
still open even that stuff shut down for
a couple days when because the water
pressure went low so it's like you have
potential water seepage into the void
system so then you can't consume fresh
water for somebody to boil everything
yeah boil it was seriously it was like
you know even Universal Studios before
on the tram tour and you go through the
the 747 or whatever yeah it was like
that that's what it felt like at least
and it did look like that - to some
extent crazy well I'm happy that you
made it out me to you seems like you
made through you know in a way stronger
yeah I think so and that's kind of like
I know it's weird saying that you feel
it was I don't know say it was a good
thing but I'm glad that we were able to
come up with a sweater lining yeah so
well I mean you said you really saved
the most important
when you've got the vania I'm not joking
I this really was high on my party not
specifically because of you but because
it was the video yeah yeah because I
mean it was let me try this thing on
let's let's take this is the shirt
you're wearing a new purchase take this
garbage as being a shirt this trash is
going in the incinerator burn that don't
call it trash oh yeah right well yeah oh
[ __ ] we got it sound effects turn it up
down get it on there good now like this
is my this is my coronation
[Music]
keep the music going damn this is
spiritual there you go it is it is no no
so out of hair I think the hair is
actually quite a bit of volume here let
me help you out yeah any good you're
just being shy about it
I mean generally not but it's mine now
right I'm keeping it like yes for me you
don't want this smoke is smoke needs to
be sort of better packaged - so you're
gonna control this let's do a gag keep
the music on here today
wait wanna do you want to control it
either yeah okay so this is the mallet
oh my god it's like a living please
don't laugh yeah and then the smoke you
kind of can just like pump it up so does
the fan work now I can I can move my
head around so do that to the mouth eula
today what's up today my coronation
today I'm born
is it moving no it's fixing I'm getting
brain surgery hands-on okay I see what's
going on here not very subtle
oh no we're gonna today okay are you
ready yeah
today is my [ __ ] touch the fan okay
today okay here we go
is it vaping I don't know is it am i
doing okay here we go yeah oh yeah add a
nice cloud are you on the Cielo yeah
today is my coronation before I was at
be any peasant but now I have truly
ascended I'm really bad with this to be
you want me to maybe I should you can't
read my mind so this is the benefit now
that'll go easy on the smoke that's on
the left my head a little bit that's
fine kind of smoke I put I go up now
you're smoking today lots of smoke is
what's the difference went up and down
cuz I can't sound closes the mouth so
it's open now this is full open in the
school clothes yeah okay today today is
my coronation the smell that's good I am
no longer put this work back beanie
peasant but I have transcended through
the beep beanie god I just waiting for
the flames to rough beanie God is a baby
at the smoke yeah that might my Creator
has built me to emulate the we're a
small chance exists that I will sit set
on fire kill anyone who wears me god
bless I was my mouth thing was it good
okay I think this fits I think I did the
bed thank you everyone wrapped round of
applause for the beanie gunner god bless
man
thank you thank you thank you thank you
can I just do the rest of the show like
this yeah just don't pump the smoke I
was my mouthing you're improving quick
Eli's my mouth ain't working good you're
really good at it I was having trouble
yeah my head is definitely like all
right yeah well oh yeah it smells a
little like burning I like that all
right that was great I had a lot so
thank you very much I'll say William
yeah yeah thank you very much for
joining us thank you for having me
everybody please go check out Williams
Channel William Osmond on YouTube right
yeah that right that's right is there
anything else you'd like to promote or
plug or yeah can Michael Reaves I did it
first Michael Reaves you already here
[ __ ] copy ass a [ __ ]
you ever seen the laser in your eye guy
no but I hate him he oh well I mean I
want to see you should but I feel like
you shouldn't that guys yeah by the way
I want I also want to give a shout out
to William Osmonds
Vin Diesel ham sandwich video which I
have to say the thumbnail dan do you
have the thumbnail for that video
look at this probably the best thumbnail
I've ever seen where a half with the
sandwich I'm getting really into this am
i doing good yeah the half of this
that's actually a real image of Vin
Diesel sandwich he made melded into the
real face of Vin Diesel I hope I would
say 50% someone he knows showing it to
him if I hold this too long to down you
think it's dangerous
though the smoke is definitely is gone
yeah okay we probably burn the cotton
okay well once again thank you so much
well I am and really appreciate you
coming out here all the way down Ventura
your turn and do shenanigans we have
some shenanigans
we have shenanigans and material I'm
here too but if you guys have any an
indigent idea a hundred percent I think
that we definitely will have some
shenanigan ideas is this my yeah it's
going yeah you don't care anything other
than the smoke that's the only fire
hazard I'm holding I'm holding down the
smoke my hair is very flat okay I don't
see any smoke yeah all right I'm not
[ __ ] with this thing I'll get scared
anyway thank you
god bless they really appreciate you
coming out here thank you I want it to
light on fire though fire but I don't
imagine that it would go some things you
just know all right god bless man thank
you so I don't know how all right to
transition cuz we don't have a break do
I need to leave now you know yeah sure
okay so we've got let's eat look we're
moving on we are moving on to Dee god
damn frickin Ian's beef this was great
we by the way did you say that we just
posted a video oh yeah by hearing the
break we just dropped a new video with
items a collab oh he dropped one I
dropped one epic food lab review on
Ian's channel hide okay legit and and we
went shooting our weapons I was a real
old school collab yeah it was super fun
yeah it was a blast we lit we just
posted that during the break what a
multi-talented beanie God I am thank you
do you think a jewel poster do you just
send out no we never use no schedule
there's not enough planning ever your
life video is exported yeah and it's on
yes at the best maybe well I'm gonna
have the best only reason I want to post
it I think the beanies uh still me
literally about to explode oh is it this
he's this why you oh oh oh this it's not
our table well I
I'm new here
yeah the videos up but at best we'll put
it well like unlisted overnight because
we'll finish out like 10:00 p.m. and
posting isn't really an option that's
really early at 10 p.m.
yeah w no [ __ ] video yeah we pulling all
nighters pretty well single time yeah we
used to do we used to but I think we're
trying to be healthier I'm trying to
have a life and like not do that excuse
me it's hard alright but we have to
bring in and we have I update to end in
turn he we like we asked last week for
songs about Ian the intern and we got
delivered a lot of great ones
not only that Ian has an update about
the Drake Pusha T beef and not only that
but Ian somehow got invited you look
nervous in you got invited to the Kanye
listening party of what you're wearing
swag now well we got to play the song
when Ian enters all for Christ's sake we
got a 2-shot right is this white right
now
do you guys right yeah we're live do you
guys mind swapping out that's fine this
is oh yeah this this we didn't plan that
up you guess that once Ian or William
god bless you everybody please check out
Williams Channel I'm gonna put a link in
the description you get don't leave wool
watch out after I'm done if you have
time we'll finish in like 15 minutes and
we'll come hang out for a bit
that okay yeah please leave that okay
get that throw that out the window all
right yeah come on come get ridiculed
all right sit you go ahead play yeah
so that's the original but hit me hit me
with some of that new he and the
internship oh you've got him oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me
you heard all these I'm just gonna let
it play while we talk okay yeah it
sounds like Joe Joe it's nice this is
all I hear in my head so yeah tell me
about tell me about first of all is
there any updates to Drake push a TV how
did has that been resolved the beef the
beef has gone bad does that mean that
it's ended or that it's gotten worse
rotten beef like toss it out it's off
there's a and are you disappointed but
that the beef has has expired or did you
want it to stay fresh I'm glad that it's
over cuz it was getting dicey really
that seeing this in what way it was
getting more than rap I was getting too
real yeah
this guy got involved named Jay prince
who he's the head of this record label
called rap-a-lot records and he's very
intense and he was kind of like this has
to stop and if it if it didn't then some
bad stuff might have happened wow you
think shots would be fired possibly well
he was doing an interview recently and
he showed he was doing an interview with
billboard and he showed him a text he'd
got that that morning that said keep
push a tease name out of your mouth and
it was a list of all the addresses of
like his friends and family okay so
that's kind of what's a whack is Pusha T
p-- brought it there and then all of a
sudden he's like his camps like don't
even dare say my name and here I know
where you live like that's kind of wack
yeah I mean it brought it there and now
he's like don't respond well then he
told Drake he's like don't do it Drake
says he has a song ready that would end
Kanye's career I doubt that
Kanye can't even and Kanye's and he's
been wrong you know what that's such a
good line in has a really good line so
the beef is squelched there's years back
in the world of hip-hop yeah but surely
that the surely the beef will continue
in a subtle manner like these this is
deep-seated like they hated each other
before that animosity is stronger and
more repressed now than ever
well Drake's supposed to have an album
out this month so you can bet there's
gonna be some choice before it'll be a
little little subtle sneaky stuff going
on well keep an eye and let us know if
anything change okay and also finally I
wanted to ask you about them you were at
Kanye's listening party yesterday yeah
how was that it was insane it was like
mine I'm a new person now like there's
pre yesterday life right and then my
life forward dandy you have the video of
him dancing at the wheel fire please do
not used to wear Teddy fresh hats all
the time and now look what happened
completely throw us out
I'm very disappointed Murch I can never
take this off yeah I think you know I
saw a video game your your reserve back
for the most part I'd say I saw you
giving up all your primal you you've
turned into an animal you are primal you
early a tribesmen banging around there's
this bonfire and I just saw Ian out
there by himself dancing nobody was
watching I mean I was hoping some were
watching oh I hope they admire these
moves were you upset it Stanfill
recording you
just about you heard in your head when
you were dancing
this is horrible please make it stop
sorry to interrupt you what were you
saying Dan I didn't even know he was
being stealthy lurking around he
actually did come over at one point
afterwards and I was I was in the zone
yeah and I could tell after like five
seconds Dan's like alright well see ya
and he turned up beyond hit where he
yeah I'm like if you're not on this
level
he's got a year later you know yeah
there's a lot of flailing arms oh yeah
you may be again I think anybody was
noticing you think anyone's like oh [ __ ]
check this photo because the crowd was
very like oh we're cool you know let
look out yeah cuz all like invite-only
and Mariah exclusive so they were mellow
but I was just freaking out oh yeah no
god bless somebody there's got it yeah
did you see Kanye yeah I was right oh we
have pictures right Anders they're not
they're on my phone they're on we never
got those know that one and I want to
say I hope that I hope that we can get
invites and we'll San Jose the culture
correspondent that would be but until
then thank you so much yep no problem
baby appreciate you
you guys are crushing on the and songs
Thank You an the best one has got to be
and this dislike Joe gs1 I could just
let this play all day so you guys have
more in the intern songs as you're
crushing it
you weren't killing it keep sending them
in to podcasts at h3h3 productions calm
I cannot get enough of these and the
intern song so good there's really not
there's a couple other things to get to
but honestly I kind of like this tight
clean a little episode before next month
is podcast month we've got all these
crazy guests on deck we've got Tom
Segura
we've got book we've got Chris D'Elia
we've got go bo burnham go girl yogurt
yogurt him go-gurt him go get him go get
him go get him I want to hear this again
so guys with that being said I have a
bad day update honestly but we can talk
about the days next week
we try to do we try to write it not
impressed not impressed
clickbait you guys I know you're hanging
on to the edge ear seed for Arbor Day
updates next week but let me just take
this opportunity to say guys I love you
and cut them in is what I should have
said guys I love y'all so much thanks
for coming for tuning in for believing
in us or believing in the show for
spending some time these special
beautiful models together you know we
come here every week we sit down we
chitchat we act like it's just jokes but
it's not it's real and I'm meaning of
all god damn it in we were on Bobby
Lee's podcast Tiger belly last week I
highly recommend you guys go now it was
such a blast it was like going on a
double date it was such a blast I love
Bobby Lee and I love all the guys there
Delilah
she's sweet her Delilah Delilah
kalila it was close enough to be like
hangs close such a blast such a good
time new video on h3 with ID ups your
boy and a video on his channel and it
video on his so with that being said I
hope you all have a wonderful great
absolutely smashing weekend best freakin
weekend ever me Neil are gonna have a
good time we are out of town tomorrow
for my birthday and I'm just looking
forward to seeing you guys next week so
until then I'm wishing you a Tata for
now
and I do until next time thanks for
watching everybody
[Music]